on va passer à présent à notre série de
la semaine chaque jour nous avons décidé
de vous emmener sur les traces de
Léonard de Vinc oui à l'occasion du film
d'animation Léo qui retrace les années
tourangel du génie chaque soir nous vous
faisons découvrir des aspects différents
de sa vie et ce soir de sa mort puisque
nous nous sommes rendu sur sa sépulture
en la chapelle Saint-Hubert au château
d'Amboise mais saviez-vous que Léonard
n'a pas toujours été enterré ici orélien
ah bon je ne savais pas et bien vous
allez pouvoir découvrir tout cela dans
ce reportage puisque Aurélie Renaud nous
livre les derniers secrets de Léonard de
Vinc
1519 Léonard de Vincy vit au clolucé
depuis 3 ans sentant sa dernière heure
arrivée il rédige un testament son
souhait être inhumé au château royal
d'Amboise François 1 lui accorde ce
privilège Léonard de Vincy est inumé
dans la grande salle de la collégiale
Saint-Florentin situé au cœur du château
aujourd'hui on y retrouve une statue du
génie c'est l'empereur Napoléon I qui va
diligenter des des fouilles ici et c'est
l'inspecteur des beauards arsenne
housousseille qui va être amené à venir
faire ses recherches et à redécouvrir
donc la tombe de leéonard de Vincy à cet
emplacement juste juste derrière nous en
tout cas et puis redécouvrir ses restes
la tombe de Léonard de Vincy se trouve
désormais dans la petite chapelle
Saint-Hubert aujourd'hui en travaux sur
la sépulture on lit de manière
incomplète léonardus Vincy le squelette
a donc été attribué à Léonard Vinc
plusieurs éléments confirmeraient cette
hypothèse tout d'abord sa taille
1,77 conforme à celle de Léonard de
Vincy et la position singulière du
squelette le bras replié au-dessus de la
tête ce qui est un peu singulier he pour
un pour un corps et en fait ça
correspondrait à l'affection don dont
souffrait Léonard à savoir il était pour
sans doute émiplégique à la fin de sa
vie donc ave une paralysie latérale donc
on a quand même des arguments en vue de
la de la reconnaissance évidemment
d'avoir sa sépulture et puis d'avoir un
monument lié à son destin c'est une
grande chance pour nous donc ben nombre
de nos visiteurs viennent et je pense
notamment à notre clientèle italienne
pour voir ben la sépulture deonard de
Vinc et puis avoir un temps de
recueillement depuis
1874 la petite chapelle Saint-Hubert
reste ainsi la dernière demeure du génie
de
Vincy